you can tell a lot about a presidential
administration from who they hire but
you can also tell a lot about an
administration from who quits and now
Donald Trump's White House Ethics lawyer
has quit which is hugely shocking
because who could have possibly imagined
that Donald Trump even had an ethics
lawyer and was still doing all the
things that he's been doing but he did
his name was his name still is but he's
no longer the ethics lawyer James
Schultz James Schultz has resigned done
dealing with Donald Trump's ethical and
financial disclosure issues he's moving
to the I guess less stressful job of
private law practice I believe in
Philadelphia is where he previously
worked he says that it has nothing to do
with the permanent insanity of the Trump
administration I don't personally
believe that I don't know of a rational
person who would leave a job that's
going great in the White House after
just ten months or so although Schultz
has been quoted as saying oh it's
completely typical for people to stay in
these positions 12 to 18 months that may
be true we're only ten months into this
administration and it's it's gonna have
to be the Republican National Committee
or Fox News or some Republican lobbying
firm they'd better get this guy with
some huge bogus salary ASAP so that he
doesn't feel inclined to come clean
about the atrocities he witnessed while
representing Donald Trump's ethics in
the White House and I mostly get the
picture that he just wasn't getting paid
enough to deal with this degree of
insanity his salary I believe was a
hundred and forty thousand dollars and
compared to what he could likely be
making in private law practice at
relatively less stress probably wasn't
making it worth it to stay in this
position seriously though why would
Donald Trump need an ethics lawyer his
ethics or his personal philosophy as
I've said before is greed and personal
self enrichment period there really
aren't other considerations and the idea
of an ethics lawyer saying to Trump mr.
president what you're proposing to do
could really appear to be a conflict of
interest because of XYZ that just
doesn't even rate with Trump and
my imagine Trump looking kind of like
your dog looks when it hears your voice
come out of the answering machine yeah
we're just kind of look what what are
you saying a conflict of interest I
don't even understand why that matters
well that reminds me when the cat's away
the mice will play
yes so now I'm worried that people in
the White House are gonna start doing
all sorts of unethical things yeah if
you thought Trump was unethical with a
White House Ethics lawyer following him
around proverbially or literally then
just wait until they I don't expect this
position to be filled super soon I don't
know that lawyers are necessarily super
eager to become Trump's Ethics advisors
okay their time on this one they'll take
it like with many others this is one
that they're gonna take their time on
being Trump's White House ethics lawyer
is kind of like working in the gender
non-discrimination Department of Fox
News or something like that it's a
pointless job and I imagine that it's
also a futile job anyway he's gone James
Schultz is gone never knew the guy low
paid intern never gave us any advice
worth taking and he's now at a failing
fake news law firm of some kind and
we're just gonna focus on making America
great again
nobody knows who this guy even was but
he's gone and we'll never hear from him
again unless he decides to show up on
Fox News or CNN and start telling us
airing some of the dirty laundry of
Donald Trump the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as $1 per month and every dollar
helps to support the work that we're
doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad